nous vous en parlions en début de
semaine estelle halliday a obtenu
réparation parce que sur internet
étaient diffusées des photos volées du
mannequin vedette
il s'agit d'une première juridique dans
le monde car un tribunal parisien a
condamné l'hébergeur de ce site c'est à
dire celui qui permet d'accéder à
internet et non pas l'auteur du délit
qui n'est que locataire de ce site cette
décision pourrait faire jurisprudence et
inquiète les professionnels du web qui
parlent déjà de chasse aux sorcières les
explications nécessaires parce qu'elle
douce et bon eric de l'agneau valentin
lacambre internautes libertaire ne
s'attendait vraiment pas à devenir un
jour l'objet de la colère d'un mannequin
célèbre une colère qui pourrait bien lui
coûter très cher c'est tombé sur le fax
j'ai vu trois cent mille francs
saint-prime et je me suis dit ah là là
là c'est foutu
valentin lacambre et hébergeurs cela
signifie qu'il accueille dans la mémoire
de son ordinateur toutes sortes de pages
web qu il aide gratuitement à accéder à
l'internet il se rémunère en vendant
parallèlement des services
d'informatique il est loin de rouler sur
l'or un jour la belle estelle halliday
apprend que des photos indiscrètes de sa
personne sont présentés sur internet
ses avocats ne peuvent remonter jusqu'à
l'auteur du délit aujourd'hui partis
vers d'autres cieux informatique
alors ils attaquent valentin lui n'a
aucune responsabilité éditoriale sur les
sites qu'il héberge et la cour le
considère comme complice libre à lui de
se retourner contre l'auteur du délit
qu'il dit ne pas connaître ça voudra
dire que je vais payer des sommes
d'argent colossales en étant condamnée
est qu après j'irai me retourner contre
ceux qui sont probablement des petits
jeunes de 15 ans totalement à solvables
valentin n'est pas le seul à avoir des
ennuis
les animateurs du village un autre
hébergeur ont eu droit à un matin à une
visite inattendue
bah écoutez les policiers sont arrivés
à cinq par la porte avec la carte de
police dans la main reculer les mains de
vos claviers un site hébergé ici
présentait un extrait d'un film interdit
aux mineurs sans avertissement préalable
le village a pourtant l'habitude de
chasser les sites délictueux mais
comment contrôler les centaines de
milliers de pages qui l'héberge
il faudrait quelqu'un 24 heures sur 24
en train de surveiller plus de 200 wind
document maintenant qu'ils vont passer à
400 milliards mignon bientôt mais on ne
demande pas aux prestataires quels
qu'ils soient d'accès d'hébergement ou
autres de tout contrôler tout le temps
on sait bien de toute façon c'est pas
possible
mais on leur demande de faire le minimum
au moins sinon le maximum pour éviter
qu'internet devienne une véritable
poubelle
le débat est ouvert valentin lui en est
réduit à recueillir le soutien de
milliers d'internautes qui ont écris à
estelle halliday pour implorer sa
clémence